President Trump and First Lady Melania  Trump visit to the United Kingdom  they met with Queen Elizabeth and you  may have already seen some of the  pictures or the video you probably  didn't know that Queen Elizabeth was  apparently miked during the visit yes  she's miked and we were able to get a  hold of the Queen's audio during her  time today with the Trump's give a  listen sprit interesting now Donna  please don't put your grubby hands on  anything in this room this is not a  Burger King buffet at mar-a-lago this is  a book words see yummy you look confused  you've never read one have you more  countdown to gin and tonic although look  at him with his hand on his heart I know  there's nothing there you're the most  revolting guest since the Spice Girls  [Applause]